that pool really is kind of a badass new
age kind of superhero how did you how
much of it is yours oh you know there's
a lot of me in there there's a lot of
Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick are writers
there's you know it's it's a group
effort and but yeah I love it I mean I
can kind of channel Deadpool I've always
for 11 years I've been trying to get
that for me
how many more of these would you want to
make I'd love to have the opportunity to
tell three or four more Deadpool stories
I consider myself lucky to have been
able to do one Deadpool is it Ryan's
first gig as a superhero he met his wife
Blake Lively when the two starred in
2011's Green Lantern what did your wife
think of the suit she knows a thing or
two about superheroes she does she was
pretty blown away by by just how the
suit was such a faithful adaptation from
comic book to screens and my daughter
would cry when she'd see me in the scar
makeup you know it was hard she hear my
voice but she'd see this guy that looks
like a deep-fried testicle and it's it's
just that sounds like her father and
that's a you know that stop for kids et
caught up with Ryan in San Francisco on
Friday but he's not staying in town for
Sunday Super Bowl will you go to the
game no I got a one-year-old at home and
a wife waiting for me I'm gonna I'm
gonna get out of here tomorrow before
the zoo happens and uh and watch it on
the TV so yeah I think that's a key
thing you said it's hard to explain to
your wife that you're hanging out the
superball when she's stuck at home with
the bait yeah the state of the game and
I don't know maybe spend a couple extra
days just sightseeing no you don't you
don't do that you go but it's not even
for that it's for me I want to go see
them so I'm uh
GALEX I do